[Music]
I chose Public Health mainly because I
chose public health because my reason
for choosing Public Health was really
deeply rooted in my personal experiences
many things led me to Public Health
having worked as a physician in a low
and middle income country participating
in work in public health allowed me to
see that we can treat people or we can
address the needs of the people not just
one patient at the time but in a
community as a whole and that for me was
very valuable CU working in public
health allowed me to integrate
environmental engineering medicine and
public health and make and see it in the
more impactful way I remember my family
we moved from Detroit to a suburban area
outside of the city and while I was
young at the time I really couldn't
ignore the Stark differences and racial
demographics but also uh Urban
Development and uh it really sparked a
curiosity didn't know what it looked
like in meant at the time and how to
really conceptualize that now
understanding that move that I had when
I was younger from those two despair
communities just 30 m apart but had a
10year difference in life expectancy
that uh Stark difference was something
that propelled me into the field I
graduated the year that covid-19 uh
pandemic hit so who were the Frontline
workers during the pandemic it was
people like my parents it was people
like those in in my Cuban Community
immigrant Community Latina community
that were still pushed to or had to go
to work and expose themselves to
covid-19 and I had already seen people's
social and behavioral risk factors for
certain chronic diseases that were then
just made worse during the covid-19
pandemic in my own family and in my
community and that's why I came back to
to graduate school to get my masters in
public health because I feel like I can
hopefully be a mouthpiece for my
community I have been doing HIV projects
for almost 10 years and my work has
always been Community Based just seeing
that human side is so important in terms
of Designing projects that are actually
going to benefit the populations we're
trying to serve Public Health isn't just
about health outcomes it's about
analyzing our society and the
environment that we are part of and
seeing how that has an impact on our
health it's one of the fields that I uh
really I feel like can eleviate human
suffering which is something that I'm
passionate about what's really important
about public health is it's really the
Bedrock of everything and um it really
has components in almost everything here
so if we think of all the schools at
Yale Public Health has a component
within each and every
school
[Music]